[Musica]
stiamo per chiudere acp niaaa proprio
chiuso chiuso tutto onorata voce tempo a
ben
c'è una sete
[Musica]
bisoli faccia quello che vuole lei è
proprio la bibita adatta mentre cade
tutto perché tutto fasullo qua vediamo
vediamo
l'importante che sia disseta ma
assolutamente era bianche blu se posso
portare un amico o un amico luigi lui
l'ha gradita e non sono state ancora
aperti qualche minuto miei clienti nata
bene vieni ti buonasera a saperlo
portavo due bicchieri per me solo a
quadrare meglio perché meglio non bene
con la roma che è terribile prego
e poi ci si si si si rispetto a questa
che non sa non vorrei mai e questa volta
che ci lascia silete noe su così
[Musica]
ultimamente visto veramente tanto in
giro su internet interviste che ti devo
dire stupisce anche me nato momento
questo rinnovato interessamento nei miei
confronti ho visto molto felice di
questo sì sì sì mi fa far un pò pace con
questo signore qua questo ragazzo qua ma
come mai colmare ma insomma sono stato
morto per parecchio è mica da poco
mi ricordo qualcosa tipo questo su yahoo
non so se ti ricordano insieme non solo
toluca toni è morto per overdose ma era
anche un attore porno
vorrei ricordarlo anch'io parte ovest e
resterai per sempre un bel lavoro trova
infatti cioè che poiché elfi ma poi mica
lo possono fare tutti o infatti da
quello che ho percepito io con questa
intervista è un po quello che abbiamo
percepito tutti soprattutto quelli della
mia generazione torna ai 30 anni e che
non è stata presa molto bene questa cosa
qui da te e becca tira insomma tanto ma
io non è che son morto perché sono
salvato un gattino dall'albero se non
avevo fatto vuol dire come l'eroe non ne
sapesse come abbastanza spessa come come
e poi è arrivata in un momento in cui le
tecniche usa ancora non erano non si
riusciva ancora decodificarli un errore
e quindi per anni tutti hanno neppure la
mia vicina di casa anche se fosse morto
fossi morto e che fossi un sosia per cui
ti dico e stata una cosa per me è molto
pesante adesso parte gli scherzi
molto dura molto pesante hai cercato di
fare qualcosa perché ti ha colpito molto
forte gli hai cercato di fare qualcosa
certo ho fatto anche delle denunce o
insomma poi però come mi dissero le
notizie sul web sono come un sasso
dentro l'acqua si formano i cerchi il
sasso non lo trovi più intanto si sta
quindi non riesce a risalire a chi sa
chi potrebbe essere stato l'artefice di
tutto questo da qualche idea allora
diciamo quello che mi dissero all'epoca
i
i due ispettori ministro guarin 99 per
cento lo diciamo arriva dal suo ambiente
di lavoro
poi io rimasi un po così semmai è vero
significa che l'invidia c'è e non morirà
mai però di solito sai dopo un po passi
invece quanto tempo ci ha messo per
passare 15 anni vent'anni contro dal
2006 mamma meno 12 anni 12 anni e tanto
si per rimanere morto 12 anni però non è
che sei stato davvero molto se non ti
sei mai fare anche perché poi ad esempio
nel 2007 ho fatto un programma per
bambini sempre sulla rai trebisonda
bisogno due anni nel 2010 un programma
di cucina per bambini su alice tv poi
sono tornato in melevisione come cuoco
insomma non è che proprio più lo ero
c'era forse questa volontà proprio di di
immaginarmi morto come dico sempre al
mio funerale quello vero non ci sarà
nessuno penseranno che c'è un'america
anche questo a quel punto per importi
rai4 votarvi ma a proposito di questo tu
che sei morto già se hai potuto leggere
quello che la gente pensava di te per
davvero quel si saluta di sempre e
questa è la cosa così accade cosa ha
detto l'agente perché molte cose erano
veramente un po infamanti n erano
proprio perché è sempre legato appunto a
questa a questa presunta morte anche per
per il web e morte certa però insomma
per overdose ragazzi no perché c'erano
queste specie le massime specie voli se
tavernello mira a casa al correr stretto
grazie per averla letta
cioè non dovevo loro ricerche
assolutamente sì
[Musica]
io voglio sapere se perdono al francese
cosa cazzo è slurp
io voglio che perché io per prepararmi
questa cosa ho detto ok ha fatto
trebisonda ok lo conoscevamo e poi ha
fatto sviluppo ti giuro su dio danilo
non c'è un'immagine una non c'è il logo
che cos'è sviluppo era un programma di
cucina per bambini
poverino che insegna a cucinare
pasticciare ahi ahi da mino fatto anche
una cheesecake per la barbie è arrivato
allarmi in carne ed ossa bellissima e
trojan blog ovvero il blog di cucina che
adesso abbandonato perché non riesco più
a starci dietro
ho peccato molto impegnativa ma o scrive
i copioni per il programma per cui
scrivo oppure cucina certo mi piace
abbiamo messo un nome del programma per
cui la mano per bambini che si chiama la
posta di yo yo
la posta migliaia esattamente del
proprio quello esattamente quello non ti
sei grotto non certo finito di lavorare
per i bimbi per pubblico di bambini in
generale beh allora i bambini è il
pubblico più più bello il pubblico più
vero e di quello dove tasti veramente la
la tua capacità di comunicazione perché
ai bambini o piace o non piace
io riesco a comunicare con i bambini sì
mi piace fare questo lavoro e adesso
scrivere un programma per bambini mi
piace molto mi diverte un commento poi
però vorrei anche tornare in video
questo qualcuno magari fare qualcosa non
lo so una conduzione barman toscana ed
ha incontrato è ancora lunga sono lunghi
sai cosa sarebbe bello da lillo a casa
sarebbe bene se tu fossi partecipe di
una delle fasi protagonista di una
puntata di la posta di yo yo quale come
sono naturale hai visto 12 anni di video
non so parlare
sarebbe bello se sarebbe bello è una
domanda a cui devo rispondere sarebbe
bello
ecco qua la posta allora adesso io
dovrei leggere un po di commenti che
sono apparsi sul web un pò pin
noli non so cosa leggero quindi va beh
ci prova a claudio due mesi fa e shiloh
che belle ville c'è anche ma darsi al
porno così fa tutti contenti ma ciò
netta la mamma su tutti bellissimi però
io penso mi avesse dato dei messaggi un
po più cattivi rebel art
bono incredibile lo vedo spesso dalle
mie parti di torino nelle vie del centro
quanto voi quanto vorrei essere il suo
album
[Musica]
allora se perde il lavoro andrai
riassumete voi ve lo dico
[Musica]
l'agente associate alla melevisione da
da tutto da da tanti anni mentre proprio
banalmente milo ha fatto molti più anni
di te un veterano della melevisione i
fan italiani prima fatti 4 alla fine
meglio è andato con i ragazzi di space
vale anche lui a quanto pare molto molto
aperto per il senso contesto divertente
e quindi è incredibile e incredibile
porte avervi entrambi su a casa nostra
tra virgolette
a gennaio
hai fatto tra vincolata molte virgolette
coming out perché tu non è che hai hai
detto di essere tu che semplicemente non
l'hai mai detto perché non c'era e c'è
una cosa si è difatti tutti che che mi
riguarda alcune anche con dei commenti
cari ma potevi farlo prima
avresti vissuto bene tutti questi anni
io ho vissuto bene se se se questo è
servito a qualche ragazzo per prendere
coraggio e dichiararsi che sono in
famiglia o sul posto di lavoro eccetera
ben venga però valori della reazione
perché dico non solo è tornato in vita
che è il mio peso la faccia di postal
iii si è capito e io questo l'ho portata
a parecchi anni cioè l'anno scorso così
prima ancora è tutto questo quindi come
dire allora forse era già successo
l'anno scorso questo esattamente a parte
il fatto che gli fa mi fa molto piacere
vedere che siete indistinguibili e si
somiglia si piglia come si sa
esattamente questo
quello che traspare è che tu abbia un po
quasi un risentimento nei confronti di
tonio ma no è che come dire c'è stato un
periodo per cui era molto difficile
anche per me scindere uscire da questo
personaggio però era proprio molto
difficile la mia vicina di casa ha
continuato per tutti questi anni
chiamarmi toni ho capito la gente a ciao
tony
quindi era un personaggio ingombrante
lui nella mia vita
questo è esattamente ha iniziato
effettivamente ad essere magari sull
innervosito linke periodo da quando hai
finito la melevisione in poi hanno
intanto la la scelta di lasciare il
programma è stata una scelta mia perché
ritenevo fosse arrivato il momento di
provare a fare qualcos'altro e non come
dire abituarsi ad un personaggio è
cominciato a diventare un po ingombrante
nel momento in cui appunto sono uscite
queste uscite a questa femmina ho capito
quindi è stata l'amato stilisti lire un
po autore che problema con lui nel senso
ce l'avevo con lui ma la mia l'acqua
come ti fa parlare visto che poi il fine
serata
io però voglio sapere quale storia dei
fan perché alla fine il bar l'abbiamo
aperto quasi concettualmente per quello
poi si è trasformato però secondo me
niente racconta meglio l'esperienza di
una persona che le sue esperienze con i
fan
non vorrei sembrare un copione con un
ospite che mi ha preceduto qui però ad
esempio a napoli ricordo che una mamma
arrivo con questo bambino piccolo
visa in braccio antonio perché a napoli
mi chiamavano antonio non sta male
predil ha detto dio sta male e ho
cominciato a fare mente locale di tutte
le malattie infettive che poteva avere
la rosolia il morbillo di crociera avrei
avuto alle sue matta questa cosa che la
gente piace lanciare neonati o bonsai
vip per bene siamo a fine serata al bar
se vuoi dire qualcosa per sfogarti qui
siamo è un bar per fatto apposta è fatta
apposta siamo la sera ci sono solo io
poi non so quante lo guarderà pochissime
persone proprio col cavolo che stavo
quando lo space valle
[Musica]